digamos que tenemos la función gdx igual
a la integral definida desde 19 hasta x
de la raíz cúbica de t dt y tenemos
curiosidad de encontrar que prima de 27
a que es igual pausa el vídeo y trata de
pensar en la respuesta pero antes te
daré una pequeña pista piensa en el
segundo teorema fundamental del cálculo
muy bien vamos a trabajar juntos si
queremos encontrar que prima de 27
primero podemos intentar encontrar g
prima y después evaluarla en 27 y la
mejor forma en la que podemos hacerlo es
realizar la derivada de ambos lados de
esta ecuación así que vamos a realizar
la derivada de ambos lados de la
ecuación del lado izquierdo vamos a
realizar la derivada de gtx con respecto
a x y del lado derecho vamos a realizar
la derivada de todo esto con respecto a
x del lado izquierdo tenemos algo
bastante directo la derivada deje de x
con respecto a x es que prima de x y
ahora cuál es la derivada del lado
derecho
bueno aquí es donde el segundo teorema
fundamental del cálculo es útil vamos a
escribirlo el segundo teorema
fundamental del cálculo nos dice que es
la función f mayúscula de x es igual a
la integral definida de una constante
x de la función efe minúscula de té de
té y nuestra función
efe minúscula de x es continua en el
intervalo de x y lo escribiremos así si
es continua en el intervalo cerrado de
aa x entonces la derivada de f mayúscula
de x es decir f mayúscula prima de x va
a ser igual a nuestra función interna
efe minúscula evaluada en x en lugar de
de es decir
efe minúscula de x
sé que cuando viste esto por primera vez
pensaste que podría ser algo críptico
que no podría usarse con demasiada
frecuencia pero veremos que en realidad
es muy útil y algunos de ustedes ya
saben que hay múltiples formas de pensar
una integral definida como ésta o lo
aprenderán en el futuro sin embargo con
esta forma se puede simplificar
demasiado en especial cuando tienes una
integral definida peliaguda como esta
entonces esto nos dice que observa
cuando realizamos la derivada con
respecto a x de todo esto primero
tenemos que revisar que nuestra función
interna que es análoga a nuestra función
efe minúscula por acá sea continua en el
intervalo cerrado de 19 a x pero sin
importar el valor de x esta función va a
ser continua en este intervalo porque
ésta es una función continua para
cualquier x
así que cumplimos con nuestra primera
condición o nuestra condición más
importante y entonces podemos decir que
la derivada de todo esto va a ser
nuestra función interna reemplazando a t
con x
por lo tanto obtenemos la raíz cúbica y
en lugar de poner a t pondremos a x la
raíz cúbica de x y por lo tanto podemos
regresar a nuestra pregunta original a
que equivale g prima de 27 bueno
equivale a la raíz cúbica de 27 qué es
y hemos acabado